that as for how much of the vaccine our
state has the health district received a
total of 12
675 doses developed by pfizer 8 news now
reporter sally jeremiah joins us live
from the health district
with a look at what is now the
distribution timeline
sally bryant vaccine arrived
here at the southern nevada health
district around 8 a.m this morning it
was then distributed to umc
and in the coming days it will be
distributed to other hospitals
let me tell you how all of this
technically works the health district
receives the vaccine
in phases a distribution plan has been
developed to ensure
the initial supplies of vaccine are
provided to the critical population
such as health care personnel and groups
most at risk for direct exposure to the
virus
long-term care facilities are also
included in tire 1
tier 1 and will be receiving the vaccine
supplies from pharmacy providers
we actually sent out surveys prior to
this
and looking at one hospital survey
it looks like around 60 70 percent
we surveyed our own and we had a higher
about a similar number
and maybe some other groups on the tier
were about 50 50.
so i i think there was a very positive
mood this morning
the pfizer vaccine was granted emergency
use authorization from the food and drug
administration
it's a two dose series those receiving
the first dose
will need to get a second in three to
four weeks now a separate batch of doses
will be distributed to places such as
cvs and walgreens and next week
reporting live sally haramigno 8 news
now all right sally thanks for that
report but before you go the vaccine has
to be kept in a special freezer
super super cold what is the procedure
for administering the shot and keeping
it that cold
so once it's taken out from the freezer
bryant you have to leave it out for 30
minutes at least and it has to be used
within the six hours